الطفل عمر ولد قبل ساعه واحده جاء الى
الدنيا في ظروف بالغه التعقيد اثرى الحرب
التي تدور روحاها قرب المشفى الذي يقع شرق
الخرطوم رغم ذلك فقد وهب املا كبيرا
لاسرته بقدومه واملا اخرا للاطباء الذين
حضروا في ذات المكان وفات اطفال قبل ولاده
عمر نقص الاكسجين جعل هذه الحضانه
الطبيعيه في مستشفى دريما التخصصي لا
تستطيع ان تستقبل عدد من الحالات التي يتم
ولادتها هنا في المستشفى او تاتي من
الخارج الحاجه اللي بتقطع القلب انه يعني
المستشفى ده استقبل حاله طفل ناقص مستشفى
التركي مشي مستشفى المنوره لما يفعج
ولدت لكن البيبي كان خلاص الطفل كان ناقص
تتجهز سناء الطيب لدخول غرفه العمليات فقد
استطاعت الوصول للمستشفى في الوقت المحدد
لها رغم التوترات الامنيه والله الشارع في
توتر لكن يعني الحمد لله ما واجهتنا صعوبه
يعني في انه نوصل للمستشفى وكده حاليا
يعني يحددوا لي عمليه وان شاء الله بعد
ساعه او ساعتين
ان شاء الله رب العالمين
استمرار الحرب التي صعبت وصول الامداد
الدوائي وانقطاع الكهربائي لساعات وايام
طويله يهدد باستمرار تقديم الخدمات الصحيه
بصوره مقبوله المستشفى 18 يوم وكانت
كهرباء قاطعه طوال يعني كنا بنضطر نحن
بنوفر الجهاز
زي ما بيقولوا بالسوق الاسود يعني
بالمستشفى مختص واحد فقط يعمل دون انقطاع
منذ قرابه الشهر ويناشد بضروره توفير بعض
المساعدات حتى لا تتوقف الخدمه تمينا ما
يقارب واربعين يوم شغالين المستشفى ما
يقبل مشكله الاكسجين كده الفتره الاخيره
يعني عندنا عدد اسطوانات بسيطه لكن دايرين
يعني
محتاجين يعني لان احنا شغالين عليه عمليات
بنحتاج كميه بتاع الدم
يبدو الوضع متازيما جدا وصعبا لعده نواقص
اساسيه بسبب الحرب فهذه الاسطوانات فارغه
ولا تستطيع ان تهب الصغار الخدجه جرعه
الحياه في زمن الحرب عمار ابو شيبه
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات